en el vídeo anterior vimos la situación
en la que teníamos que comprar un camión
cada tres años ya que sólo duran tres
años y al principio estábamos poniendo
al camión como un gasto un gasto de 60
mil dólares pero ocasionaba algo muy
extraño en nuestras operaciones de
ganancia pues hacía parecer que en los
años en los que compramos el camión
nuestro negocio iba mal y en los otros
años nuestro negocio iba bastante bien
en el vídeo anterior surgió la idea de
que cambiáramos esto haciendo lo que se
llama capitalizar el camión o el gasto
del camión lo que hacemos es en lugar de
decir que el camión es un gasto decimos
que estamos comprando un activo algo que
tiene una vida útil más allá del momento
en el que hicimos la compra aquí abajo
vamos a escribir una hoja de balance al
inicio del primer año tenemos que
nuestra baja de balance hoja de balance
y al capitalizar el camión lo que
estamos diciendo es que esos 60 mil
dólares que usamos en efectivo para
comprar el camión lo vamos a apuntar en
nuestra hoja de balance
un activo que es el camión camión vamos
a escribir lo mejor de sí
en la categoría de activos tenemos un
camión y decimos que cuando está
nuevecito vale 60 mil dólares y no
tenemos ningún pasivo eso lo ponemos en
cero por lo que nuestro patrimonio neto
60.000 0 pues nos queda 60.000 nuestra
empresa vale 60 mil dólares en los
libros la forma en que vamos a
contabilizar este camión durante los
próximos tres años es que decimos bueno
esto tiene una vida útil de tres años
pues vamos a repartir esos sesenta mil
dólares en los tres años de vida útil
otra forma de verlo es decir que este
camión nos cuesta 20 mil dólares por año
y otra forma que podemos ver esto es que
podemos despreciar el valor del camión y
esa depreciación es un gasto
depreciación del camión y aquí en lugar
de llamarle camión le voy a poner la
depreciación del camión pueden ver que
esta es una manera de repartir el costo
del camión en el primer año vamos a
depreciar nuestro camión por 20 mil y
aquí en lugar de poner 60 vamos a poner
aquí que vale un tercio de su costo
original ahora vale 20 mil menos al
final del año que de lo que valía al
principio
y en el segundo año igual 20.000 en el
tercero también 20.000 así que estamos
distribuyendo los 60 mil durante los
tres años de la vida útil y lo que esto
hace es que hace consistente nuestras
operaciones de ganancias que es como
debe de ser pues tenemos un negocio muy
consistente nos va a quedar que hacemos
30 en el primer año 30 en el segundo año
30 en el tercer año y así continuamos y
como tenemos un negocio muy consistente
vamos a estar generando 30 mil dólares
cada año durante todo ese tiempo que es
lo que hace la depreciación a nuestra
hoja de balance vamos a ver al inicio
del primer año tenemos un camión que
vale 60 mil dólares si nos adelantamos
hasta el final de este primer año o el
inicio del segundo año lo que va a pasar
es que cómo vamos a depreciar este
camión en nuestra hoja de balance vamos
a quitar 20 mil dólares de la
depreciación del valor del camión por lo
que el valor del camión va para ser de
60 mil a 40 mil así que en este segundo
año escribimos el valor del camión en
40.000 al final del segundo año
principios del tercer año el valor
continúa depreciándose y en los libros
va a aparecer como 20 mil al final
tercer año llegará a cero habrá tenido
toda su vida útil y será necesario
comprar un nuevo camión por lo que
invertiremos otros 60 mil y esto se
repetirá lo genial acerca de esto es que
el gasto se mantiene muy consistente y
eso refleja la consistencia de lo que
genera nuestro negocio